next up some news from another woman who
breaks the mold the endlessly talented
jenny slate she is one of my favorite
people and i'm happy to report that it's
time to fire up those tear ducts because
marcel the shell the famous character
that she created is getting a movie
jenny is bringing the little shell to
the big screen that she created with
dean fleisher camp in the director's
seat and they created marcel together a
decade ago please take a look at this
sometimes
i find my mind wandering
thinking
what would my family think
do you think they could be out there
[Music]
let's forget about being afraid just
take the adventure okay
let's do it
oh my god
i cannot wait i'm not kidding i have
chills everywhere and guess what
on the phone right now we've got marcel
the shell
[Applause]
hi guys oh it's actually jenny hi
oh i love you hi guys oh jenny i love
you guys so much thank you so much for
coming on this show i've been texting
you uh night and day is it like true
that marcel might be the closest to your
ooey gooey center yeah i will say that
you know marcel and the way he is and
his his easy confidence and his
immediate connection to things that are
really beautiful and important
maybe it's not like i think it's like
closest to what i aspire to be like you
know they're like it's like closest to
my best self and that's why he's a great
character to perform because i uh i get
to step into that mode and the more i
step into it the more i can replicate it
in my own life and i think that's just a
huge privilege do you think that marcel
could come to the phone
oh yeah um marcel you are on the big
screen
uh what do you hope that people will
take away from this movie
i guess i just want
um everyone to know that um
it's not only about me because i'm
extraordinary but because um actually
everybody has an interesting story if we
just take the time to
get to know them and let them be
comfortable enough to be themselves
so i guess i'm trying to be modest also
all over like here but i hope everyone
enjoys maybe
oh
myself
you're right marcel you're
[Applause]
one of my favorite minds and hearts
out there i mean
jenny as a writer i love you as an
actress i love you as a comedian i love
you
and obviously i love marcel the shell
with shoes on comes out in theaters june
24th be aware
get it while it's hot and marcel has had
a lot to teach us over the last decade
and it's
definitely a good thing that he has his
own movie so that we can all continue
to love and learn from martha marcel the
movie star
[Music]